riding a bike in London can seem like
taking your life into your own hands
normally traffic here is extremely heavy
birth times are changing
more cyclists are taking to the streets
Phillip Thornton rides his bike
everywhere he cycles some 20,000
kilometres a year
the cyclist in London has to be quite
confident and when you're left with the
road like this maybe you're a confident
cyclist it's not really much of a
problem but you have to be going get
more or less the speed of the traffic a
new presence on the road has to be quite
strong architect Philip Thornton and his
family are pleased that more and more
Londoners are discovering the joys of
cycling they're all cycling enthusiasts
from the time they were young the
children rode their bikes to school
there's still something of an oddity in
London but that could soon change
in schools there's some buy programs to
get people cycling so the next
generation I think we'll definitely be
more confident on the by personally
think they should just go ahead and
close 50% of all side streets just close
them the cars don't need to go on fifty
percent so give access to everybody
close as much as possible those kinds of
demands get London's taxi drivers all
riled up the city's cabbies are among
cyclists greatest critics no cycles get
rid of all them get rid order cycles all
the buses get rid of them their nuisance
the traffic at the moment is terrible
so by closing roads on whatever making
more cycle lanes it's just going to make
the traffic even worse it's dangerous
because half the people that Sartre at
the moment don't know the highway
current and the small percentage do know
the highway code don't adhere to it so
there should be some sort of a test for
cyclists and yet
London's inner city is currently
swarming with bicycles has the corona
crisis assured in a new age of mobility
cyclists now have some powerful
supporters behind them there'll be a
huge amount of planning going to helping
people to get to work other than by mass
transit and this will be I hope I know
that my rival friend will as a former
secretaries of transport will agree this
is or should be a new golden age for
cycling but they must act fast
when commuters return on mass there
won't be enough buses or trains to
accommodate them and adhere to social
distancing measures if even a small
percentage of these commuters start
using cars instead London will be faced
with total gridlock the temptation to
get into motorcar will be very very
strong and understandable so I think
we've got a short window of time to
reach out to both the politicians and to
the public at large to say there is a
better way of doing this as the city
London's financial district is leading
the way during the death access is
restricted to buses and bikes only
and sidewalks are being widened to give
pedestrians more room and in some
residential districts streets are being
closed to through traffic drivers are
having to find other routes just in
these few weeks there is an amazing
opportunity to to connect a lot of the
unconnected parts and to get the local
councils on board to get the local roads
designated for cycling and to stop this
car century during the corona crisis
London feels a bit more like bike
friendly Amsterdam Phillip Thornton and
his family hope it will stay that way
though this new golden age for cycling
seems almost too good to be true
[Music]